في الولايات المتحدة، عادةً ما يكون ماء الصنبور آمنًا
للشرب، ويحتوي الجهاز الهضمي لدينا على
العديد من الأدوات والأجزاء المختلفة
لجهاز المناعة لدينا للمساعدة في الحفاظ على سلامتنا، ولكن
يمكن أن تكون المياه والأجهزة الطبية خطيرة، وفي حالات نادرة حتى
مميتة إذا أدت إلى إصابة الدماغ.  العدوى
وقد لا يعرف الكثيرون ذلك، فقد قال غالبية
الأشخاص الذين شاركوا في استطلاع عام 2021
بشكل غير صحيح أن مياه الصنبور يمكن
استخدامها لشطف الأنف أو شطف
العدسات اللاصقة وأنها آمنة للاستخدام في
أجهزة التنفس مثل جهاز
ترطيب الهواء CPAP أو وعاء neti.  إذا فكرت
في الطريقة التي نشم بها تلك الأعصاب، فإنها تنتقل
مباشرة من أعلى أنفنا
إلى دماغنا، وبالتالي
قد تكون في بعض الحالات قناة مباشرة
للعدوى، يقول الدكتور كارا ووتر من
مركز ويكسنر الطبي بولاية أوهايو، إن هناك
طرقًا سهلة  حافظ على سلامتك أولاً، يمكنك
شراء الماء المقطر أو المعقم من
متجر البقالة أو شركة الإمدادات الطبية في
حالة شطف الأنف بواسطة
علبة معقمة ممزوجة مسبقًا من محلول ملحي أو يمكنك
غلي ماء الصنبور الخاص بك، فهو يحتاج إلى الغليان لمدة
دقيقة واحدة تقريبًا إذا كنت''  إذا كنت على
ارتفاع أعلى، فسوف تحتاج إلى
تمديد ذلك لمدة ثلاث دقائق تقريبًا ويمكنك
ترك هذا الماء يبرد واستخدامه
لخلط محلول الماء المالح
عند استخدامه بشكل صحيح، يقول الماء إن
الشطف والمنتجات المالحة هي طريقة رائعة
لمساعدتك على الشعور  من الأفضل ألا أشعر بالخوف الشديد
ولكني سأتخذ أيضًا هذه
الخطوات الإضافية للتأكد من أنك تفعل ذلك
بأمان لمدة نصف دقيقة، أنا ماندي جايثر